a sense of humor is the most wonderful  thing in the world  because it makes you human but there's a  more even more valuable thing about a  sense of humor which is you cannot laugh  and be sad at the same time you cannot  laugh and be scared at the exact same  time and so i think maintaining a sense  of humor especially in difficult times  is essential  because when we're under huge amounts of  stress at work and somebody cracks a  good joke it actually puts us in a great  frame of mind to come together and  attack that problem to overcome that  challenge so believe it or not i  actually think a good sense of humor is  essential to great leadership it  actually helps us come together and and  make it through adversity